[Music]
foreign
so in the last few lectures we showed
how to solve Matrix Systems of
differential equations x dot equals ax
where X is a vector of states and a is a
matrix so this is a coupled system of
first order differential equations and
what we showed was that by finding the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this
Matrix a we can transform this system
into a diagonal form where it's easier
to solve so now I'm going to give you a
few examples and in this lecture I'm
going to start with a specific example a
matrix maybe I'll use orange so I'll use
one of the a matrices that we've looked
at before which is 3 negative 1 negative
one three three negative 1 negative one
three
and we've already computed the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of this a
matrix in one of the last lectures so
this was one of the examples of how to
compute eigenvalues and eigenvectors so
if I remember what we have is the Matrix
of eigenvectors was I think it was like
one one one minus one
and the Matrix of eigenvalues this
diagonal matrix D is I think it was a
diagonal of two zero zero four so we had
two eigenvalues two and four and these
two corresponding eigenvectors so the
eigenvector corresponding to eigenvalue
2 is 1 1 and the eigenvector
corresponding to eigenvalue four is one
minus one okay good and so now what
we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through
and compute the solution of this
differential equation with this a matrix
using that formula we had before and I
believe that formula was something like
um you know X of t
X of t
equals e to the a matrix I'm going to
maybe drop the sub you know under bars
for Matrix we know this is a matrix e to
the Matrix a t
times initial condition X naught and we
wrote this e to the a t as I believe we
wrote it as T times
e to the diagonal matrix
times time
times T inverse
times x naught
and so I know what Big T is my Matrix of
eigenvalues I know what diagonal matrix
D is and so now all I have to do is
compute this T inverse and we're good
we're golden we can write down this full
solution so I'm going to do that and
then I'm going to draw the phase
portrait I'm going to actually draw in
the kind of X1 X2 plane what do all of
the possible trajectories of this system
look like
good so I'm going to compute T inverse
really quickly this is pretty easy this
is just kind of like a review of Matrix
algebra really so this is not super
duper interesting if you already know
how to compute T inverse just fast
forward past when I compute T inverse so
to compute T inverse the technique I
still use the same technique that we
were all taught in kind of high school
where you go through a bunch of row
operations so what you do is you start
with the Matrix you want to invert on
the left one one
1 minus one this is just the T Matrix
and then next to it maybe I'll actually
use colors here next to it you draw the
identity Matrix one zero zero one
and what you do is you go through the
motions of row operations like you know
subtract this Row from this row or
divide this one by negative one things
like that until the green Matrix on the
left looks like the identity and you
apply all of those operations to the
blue Matrix on the right and in the
process of making this left Matrix the
identity you will turn this Matrix into
the inverse of T kind of cool maybe I'll
have a whole lecture on why that's true
you can just take that for granted right
now that that is true uh and so I'm just
going to go through pretty quickly
um so the first thing I'm going to do is
subtract this Row from this
so that's uh uh I'm sorry what am I
going to do I'm going to subtract the
first row from the second one
to get one one
zero minus two so I subtracted this Row
from this row to try to turn this guy
into a zero and I do the same thing with
my blue over here
so the bottom row is now negative one
one
good
now what I do is
I'm going to divide this second row by
negative 2 because I want this to be
diagonal I want to be one one and zeros
off the diagonal so I'm going to divide
this by negative 2 and this row by
negative 2. and so again nothing changes
on the first row it's still one one but
now this becomes 0 1 because I divided
by negative two
similarly nothing changes up here but
now this row gets divided by negative
two so now I have one half and negative
one-half
or 0.5 if you like
and then finally
um is this the last step the last step
is I'm going to now subtract this uh
this Row from the first row to kill this
uh this guy here okay so maybe I'll just
write it down here because I don't want
to mess up my board
so the last step is now subtracting the
bottom row from the top row so this
actually turns into the identity
and now you can see that if I subtract
the bottom row of Blue from the top row
I get one half minus a minus a half is
another one half
one half minus one-half so point five
point five point five minus 0.5 is the
inverse of 1 1 minus one okay that's how
we do the inverse that took a couple of
minutes not a big deal
um I really hope I didn't mess that up
but I think this is okay
and I'll just write that out here that t
inverse
equals 0.5
0.5 0.5
minus 0.5
and so now I can actually write out the
full honest-to-goodness solution of my
differential equation maybe I'll go back
to Pink here by taking this T Matrix
times e to the diagonal D times T
inverse okay so I think I'm actually
just going to write this out so X of T
equals
my Matrix t
which is 1 1 1
minus 1.
times my Matrix e to the diagonal D
times T and we know that this
exponential of this diagonal matrix
times time is just another diagonal
matrix with those exponentials so it's
another diagonal matrix with e to the 2T
and e to the 4 t on the diagonals zero
zero
okay good and now I have t inverse times
T inverse equals you know 0.5 0.5
minus 0.5
all of that
times x naught okay this is what x
of T equals and I'm just going to
multiply this out this is actually
pretty easy to solve so I'm just going
to do it
um
this equals uh one one one minus one
times okay now I'm going to multiply
these two matrices and so I take this
guy knock it over on its side times this
row times this row so I get 0.5
e to the 2 T time and then on the bottom
point five e to the 4 T that's my left
column my right column I take this
second column knock it on its side and
multiply each of these rows and again I
get 0.5 e to the 2T and I get minus 0.5
e to the 4T pretty easy all of that
times x naught
and finally I'm going to multiply this
matrix by this Matrix
um let's hope I don't mess anything up
multiply again same same basic formula
and I'm going to get
um
what am I going to get here yeah I'm
going to get
um
0.5
e to the 2T
plus 0.5 e to the 4 t
down here I'm going to get 0.5 e to the
2T minus 0.5 e to the 4 T and then for
the right column I'm going to have 0.5 e
to the 2T minus 0.5 e to the 4 T and
then the bottom right is going to be 0.5
e to the 2T negative negative is plus
plus 0.5 e to the four T all of that
times
um and now I'll actually write this out
as a vector you know X1 initial
condition and X2 initial condition so my
initial condition Vector has two
components because this is a system of
you know X1 and X2 and so we can write
that x one at a future time and X2 at a
future time
are equal to this system of equations
now I guess if I really wanted to write
this out um completely fully what I
would do is I'd actually multiply this
guy over and I'd get X1 of T equals you
know all of this stuff times X1 naught
plus all of this stuff times X2 naught
and X2 of T is all of this stuff times
X1 naught plus all of this stuff times
X2 naught that would be the full-blown
solution in time and you could plot that
in Matlab you could play around with
this and that would be pretty easy
um
pretty easy to actually work out
um
yeah that wasn't very bad actually that
was pretty easy maybe I'll just write
this in slightly easier notation I'll
just say this is one half
of you know
e to the two t plus e to the four t uh
e to the two T minus E to the four t
e to the 2 T minus E to the four t
e to the 2T plus e to the 4T all of that
times
X1 naught and X2 not
okay so this is how you actually solve
this differential equation this is the
actual solution if you wanted you know
X1 of T multiply this out and that's the
first row the second row equation X2 of
T is equal to the second row so multiply
that out and you get just a function in
time okay
is that actually these eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are actually even more
useful like when I draw the solution of
differential equations and I'm a very
geometric pictorial person I understand
things best when I draw pictures when I
think of like the cartoon of how these
Dynamics evolve I actually don't work in
this pink or blue space here I don't
actually you know if I want us if I want
to actually write down the solution or
plot it in Matlab I might work here but
if I want to draw a picture I work up
here in eigenvector coordinates and so
that's what I'm going to show you last
is how to actually plot the solution of
this differential equation in these
phase coordinates uh with with the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors and so I
hope I saved enough space over here to
do that and there used to be this really
cool software package called P plane
um
I'll just write this up it was called p
plane and you might still be able to
download this and get it running I think
it used to run in like Java and Matlab
and you could enter an ordinary
differential equation and plot the phase
portraits that I'm about to plot for you
there are other ways of doing that but
pplane made it really really easy if you
know of another thing like this another
software package in python or Matlab
that lets you plot these face portraits
you know put it in the comments and I'll
put it in the in the description because
this is really nice to be able to do
this okay and I need some colors here so
what I'm going to do
um my eigenvectors I'm still going to
draw in Orange and my basic uh
axes I guess I'm going to draw in
in yellow here let's see am I off the
edge probably off the edge
okay that's uh
this is the X1 and x two directions okay
because this Vector X here you know is
X1 X2 stacked into a vector okay that's
what that means
and
the way I actually plot these things is
remember what our eigenvectors meant our
eigenvectors were directions in which
the Dynamics were decoupled and diagonal
meaning that in this eigenvector
direction
the Dynamics are you know kind of only
depend on that variable in that
direction and so the Dynamics in this
direction are e to the 2T
that that's like or like a z dot equals
2z that was what the the dynamical
system was and in this other eigenvector
coordinate in this other eigenvector
coordinate the Dynamics are also
decoupled and they have the Dynamics you
know Z dot equals four z a different
Dynamics so I'm going to draw these and
I think what I'm going to draw is this
eigenvector in the one One Direction I'm
just going to draw that whole plane
that whole kind of direction of
uh C1 so this is
sometimes we call this uh these
eigenvectors C so this is the C1
Direction and then the C2 Direction was
in the one minus One Direction so this
is the
C2 Direction
and I'm drawing the whole kind of C1 and
C2 planes
and again what we learned about
eigenvectors and eigenvalues was that
for this differential equation and I
wrote this down before something like
um
if you had x equals t z
then Z dot were equal to Dyna to this
diagonal matrix Z and literally Z1 and
Z2 are the components in these
eigenvector directions Z1 is how much of
my state is in disk C1 Direction that's
literally what this means so Z1 is in
this direction and Z2 is in this
direction and what that means is that in
this new coordinate system C1 C2 my
Dynamics become completely decoupled so
the Dynamics in C1 have nothing to do
with where I am in the C2 Direction and
the Dynamics in C2 have nothing to do
with where I am in the C1 Direction and
that's really really useful so anything
any component of my Vector in this
direction is going to have very simple
Dynamics which is basically you know Z
One Dot equals two times Z1 in this
direction these are the Dynamics and in
this direction
Z2 dot equals 4 times Z2
these are both unstable okay because my
diagonal eigenvalues are positive I get
e to the positive 2T and e to the
positive 4T Dynamics which means both of
those blow up to Infinity as T goes to
Infinity as T gets big you know e to the
two t gets very very large and so in
both of these directions if I start with
an initial condition and maybe I'll do
kind of you know
um
yeah if I start with an initial
condition here it's going to kind of
Follow That C1 Subspace it's never going
to kind of move off of this line because
it's again diagonal and decoupled so
um it's it's only going to move in in
that line and it's going to move with
Dynamics e to the 2T it's going to move
away from the origin faster and faster
and faster and the distance is going to
be e to the 2 T same thing with this
direction so I'm going to draw a little
unstable Arrow here maybe I'll draw this
in um
in blue I have this little unstable
Arrow here and here which says if I
start in this direction I will flee from
the origin at a rate e to the 2 T in
this C1 Direction
and similarly if I start with an initial
condition on the C2 Direction I will
also have an unstable growth of e to the
4 t
and e to the 4T grows faster than e to
the 2T so I'm going to draw two little
arrows here just to give myself a little
reminder that things actually grow
faster in the C2 Direction than the C1
Direction
and so now we're ready to draw the face
portrait kind of all of the trajectories
from any initial condition
so again if I started exactly on this C1
Vector that would correspond to a system
state that had a non-zero Z1 and a zero
Z2 if I'm like if I have nothing in the
C2 direction that means Z2 is zero and
so if Z2 starts as zero it'll always be
zero and I'll stay on this
on the Subspace so any time I start on
C1 I stay on C1 anytime I start on C2 I
stay on C2 again that means I started
with a Z2 equals something and a Z1 zero
okay that's that's the Slime but now
let's say I start with some other
initial condition I start with some
point you know here or
uh you know some some other point
we know that this this point is going to
flee from the origin it's going to grow
unstable because all of the Dynamics are
moving me away in both directions
they're moving me away but this one is
moving me away faster and it's moving me
away kind of almost twice as fast right
like e to the 4T is like this thing
squared and so that means that what I'm
going to do is I'm going to be following
these parabolas
in this direction if I started for these
different initial conditions and if I
start from an initial condition over
here I'm going to get the same kind of
parabolas
but this way
okay and these are all moving out
towards Infinity okay we know that the
system is unstable so any initial
condition except from the initial
condition at the origin all of those
initial conditions are going to blow up
similarly over here now if I have a
positive Z2
um these were kind of the negative Z2
Direction these are the positive Z2
directions these are also going to have
these kind of parabolic trajectories
where they are going to flee from the
origin
and they are going to flee faster in
this C2 Direction because that is a
bigger unstable growth rate so these are
all moving like this and similarly I can
draw this picture here
I hope you can tell I really like
drawing these pictures I've been drawing
these for a long time and so this is the
phase portrait this is kind of the
pictorial geometric picture of what any
trajectory in the system is going to do
from any point they're going to flee
from the origin with an exponential
growth rate and because the C2 or the Z2
Dynamics are faster than the C1 or the
Z1 Dynamics we know that we're going to
get these kind of parabolic uh shapes so
it's going to flee in a particular
pattern away from the origin the only
points that aren't going to is if I
started exactly at the origin where all
x equals 0 then x dot equals 0 and I
stay there that's called a fixed point
so um there is a fixed point
a fixed point
at x equals zero and that's the only
point that won't move in this system
every other point is going to move away
good so uh really really interesting
again I just used my intuition from
eigenvalues and eigenvectors to draw
this picture I didn't use this blue
formula I didn't use any of this pink
formula I used my intuition from
eigenvalues and eigenvectors to draw
this picture entirely I knew that my
Dynamics were unstable I knew that these
are the directions uh the kind of the
principal axes of of growth in this
system the the Z1 and Z2 directions and
just with that information I could draw
the space portrait
good uh we call this an unstable Source
or a node this is called an un
stable
source
it's literally like a source okay
sometimes this is called a node in
dynamical systems this is as opposed to
something called a sink if I reversed
all of these directions and I made these
negative eigenvalues all of these arrows
would be pointing in and I would have
stable Dynamics e to the minus two t e
to the minus 4T where everything comes
in that would be a stable sink or a
stable node okay so maybe I'll just take
two minutes and I'll show you kind of
what that would look like
um
where am I going to do this
maybe okay I'm going to erase this and
then I'll tell you what would happen if
this was stable just stay put
okay
so for this dynamical system with these
two unstable eigenvalues meaning that
they have a positive real part so they
grow exponentially positive
exponential in time I have this unstable
Source Behavior things blow out from the
origin exponentially fast
if I just change the direction of time
here this is actually kind of a good
exercise
if I literally just said you know x dot
equals minus this ax that's just going
to change the direction of time it's
almost like saying time reverses and
instead of everything fleeing from this
origin everything's gonna attract to the
origin I just want to show you really
quickly what changes up here what
changes here and how this diagram
changes okay so if x dot equals minus ax
so this equals you know minus three plus
one plus one minus three I'm pretty sure
and this is something you should check
in by hand in python or in Matlab is
that I'm pretty sure that T and T
inverse don't change and only D changes
so I think what that means is that D now
is going to have negative eigenvalues
negative 2 0 0 minus four
and the only
thing here is that this is going to
become Z dot equals minus 2z1 Z2 dot
equals minus 4 Z2 and now these are
negative exponentials meaning as time
goes to Infinity these actually approach
zero and all that's going to happen in
this diagram is all of the arrows are
going to reverse so all of my my arrows
going out are now going to point in
and this would be called a stable
instead of a source it's a sink just
like you turn on your faucet and water
flows into the sink and it all drains
that's kind of like what this is going
to be it's called a stable sink and I
think that's also called a stable node
in dynamical systems and I can probably
draw this picture pretty quickly I'll
just draw the real quick and dirty
sketch of this thing it's basically
going to you know have exactly the same
pattern of approach
but now all of these uh arrows are going
to be
during kind of a bad job but now all of
these arrows are going to be pointing in
towards the origin
and still in the C2 Direction they're
going to be pointing in faster than the
seat One Direction but everything is
eventually going to be pulled in to the
origin this this really shouldn't be
pointed like this they should all be
pointed into the origin I did kind of a
bad job over here they're all going into
the origin okay this is called a vector
field if you like because it's literally
a field of vectors at every Point
there's a vector pointing in a direction
and that Vector field is literally
the X1 Dot and X2 dot components the
components of this derivative form a
field of vectors pointing in this is a
stable sink okay so this is one cool
example with real eigenvalues distinct
real eigenvalues in the next few
lectures we're going to look at cases
where what if one of these is positive
and one of these is negative that's
called a saddle point
what if we have a case where these are
complex conjugate pairs maybe a plus I
and a minus I I'll show you that in that
case you get Sines and cosines kind of
oscillatory Dynamics rotating Dynamics
in this phase plane and then we'll start
looking at how you can analyze
non-linear systems with these
linearizations close to these fixed
points that's all coming up thank you
[Music]
foreign